the green knight is adapted from a 14th
century epic poem called sir gawain and
the green knight
this is a sampling of some of the
biggest questions the film probably left
you with
some that can be answered by
investigating the original text and some
meant to be unanswerable
when gawain heads off to celebrate
christmas with a king and queen his
mother opts to stay home
she says she isn't feeling up to
partying but she's very up to casting
some spells
she and three other women perform a
ritual which ultimately summons the
green knight
and you would be absolutely right to ask
why the heck she'd do that
after all if not for this summoning
gwayne would never have ended up in the
situation he finds himself in
the green knight never answers this
question but sir wayne in the green
knight does
at least kind of the thing to remember
here is who the players are
the king and queen for example aren't
just anyone they are king arthur and
queen guinevere
and gwen's mother is arthur's sister
making her morgan le faye
an enchantress and not exactly a great
sibling in the original text lepay's
intention is to frighten gwenevere and
also prove that arthur's knights aren't
as heroic as they're made out to be
whether these motors remain the same in
the green knights is unclear
one would think she might be upset that
her son winds up connected with the
green knight in such a lethal way but
she seems fine with it
perhaps she resents her son or perhaps
she believes the quest gawain must go on
thanks to the green knight will lead him
to succeeding arthur as king
either way we're never supplied with a
definitive answer
shortly into gawain's quest to find the
green chapel he comes upon a young man
hovering over the dead bodies from a
recent battle
the young man seems like he wants to
help gwen but he turns out to be a thief
both the thief and his two compatriots
leave gawain tied up while stealing both
his horse and his axe the one he got
from the green knight at the beginning
of the tale
after escaping his bonds gwen comes upon
a small cottage haunted by the ghost of
its former resident
winifred played by aaron kellyman
winifred reveals that someone chopped
her head off and dumped it in the nearby
lake
she even asked wayne if he was the one
who killed her gwayne decides to help
win it fred by fetching her head and
returning it to the rest of her dead
body in the cottage
when he does winifred reveals that the
green knight to someone gawain knows and
gwen's axe magically appears
where did the axe come from did the
thief who stole the axe kill winifred
that seems unlikely since winifred is
already decayed to a full skeleton
however time seems to operate very
strangely in the green knight so it is
possible
regardless we never find out for sure
who killed winifred or how gawain's axe
finds its way into her cottage other
than to say that maybe gwayne isn't
quite all there
speaking of which gwen spends much of
his journey without any human
companionship
as we've seen even when he does
encounter other people things don't work
out terribly well for him
beaten down by the elements and starving
he winds up eating some wild mushrooms
moments later he vomits and begins to
imagine moss growing all over his hands
although the movie never states this
explicitly it's a safe bet that those
mushrooms were a little poisonous
and a lot hallucinogenic the real
question is how long do those
hallucinations last
furthermore how reliable a narrator is
gawain even from the start
while tied up by thebes he seems to
imagine himself as a rotting skeleton
that never escaped its bonds
that alone makes it difficult to know
what's real and what isn't along wayne's
quest
and things get even more unbelievable
when gwen runs into a group of naked
giants roaming the countryside
he attempts to get them to carry him the
rest of the way to the green chapel
instead they're warded off by a fox who
spends much of the film following and
perhaps
guiding gwen on his journey are the
giants real
the green knight never answers this
question the fact that he's never aided
by the giants suggests that they're
probably just a hallucination
in fact since gawain feeds to fox some
of those wild mushrooms it's possible
they're both hallucinating
assuming the fox is real of course
weaving in and out of gwen's journey to
the green chapel is a fox who seems to
act as companion and guide
they rest in a cave together they eat
those mushrooms together and by the end
of the story the fox even speaks to
queen cautioning him away from meeting
with the green knight
is the fox friend or foe and what does
the fox represent in the larger
narrative of the green knight
boxes hold all sorts of different
symbolic meanings across history and
cultures
they can represent that a solution is at
hand or they can represent a need for
patience
sometimes they're benevolent sometimes
they're tricksters meant to be eyed
warily
in the context of sir gawain and the
green knight the fox is tied to a
specific character the wife of a lord
gwain encounters late in his travels
in the original text gwen stays with the
pair in their castle and forms a pact
with the lord the lord will provide
guane with the best food he captures in
his hunt
and in exchange gwen will give the lord
anything he gains during his stay in the
castle during this time
the lord's wife kisses gwen two times
before giving him a magical protective
green belt
the lord struggles to succeed in his
hunt that day he is of course hunting a
fox
the fox is meant to possess a similar
guile and manipulative nature as the
lord's wife does attempting to bed
gawain
in the green night the lord captures the
fox only to let it get away after gwen
refuses to give up the belt
in other words we're left open-ended
over whether or not the fox can be
trusted in the movie
the lord and his wife are not the only
two people gwen meets during his time in
the lord's castle
there is a third ever present figure
throughout this part of the film the
gray-haired perpetually blindfolded
sightless woman
she appears during meals and more
importantly she's present when the
lord's wife eventually succeeds in
seducing gwen with a green
belt who is the sightless woman and why
is she there
at no point does the green knight
directly answer this question however in
the poem sir gawain in the green knight
she's morgan le faye
and that's relevant to the film as well
at the start of his journey gawain is
given what appears to be the same green
belt by his mother
however when gowan is captured by
thieves they steal the belt along with
most of his other belongings
he is completely shocked when the lord's
wife somehow offers what seems to be the
same green belt later
one could hypothesize that it is the
same green belt and that it comes
courtesy of the sightless woman who is
actually gwen's mother in disguise
we're never told that explicitly but
that is one possible interpretation
after all both the lord's wife and
gwen's paramour back home essel are
portrayed by alicia vikander so why
couldn't his mother and the sightless
woman secretly be the same person
gawain has one ultimate end point for
his journey to meet the green knights in
the green chapel on christmas day a year
after their first encounter
we don't know why his mother conjured
the night and we also don't know who the
green knight is
beyond what appears to be a supernatural
being incapable of death
however during gwen's journey winfred
tells him the green knight to someone he
knows
later the fox wards gawain away from the
green knight explaining that the figure
is inhuman and utterly without
mercy so who exactly is the green knight
the movie never actually explains this
however in the poem sir wayne and the
green knights were told definitively who
he is
he's the lord from the castle entreated
and enchanted by morgan le faye as a
means to bring harm to arthur and
camelot
the film adaptation gives us no such
connection between the lord and the
green knight
it's possible that they're the same
person but it's more likely that in this
version the green knight isn't so much a
someone green nose but a some thing
the green knight represents the horrible
knowledge that gawain would make a bad
night a bad father and a tragically
unfit king
the green knight brings gwen this
knowledge through a merciless vision so
horrifying that gwen chooses to be
decapitated by the green knights rather
than live
do we know who the green knight really
is no but we do know what he is
wayne's mortal fate check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one